salut tout le monde ces crises pour brut
là on va parler de ma coupe de cheveux
quoi puisque mon album donc
officiellement maintenant partir
d'aujourd'hui je ne parle plus de ma
coupe de cheveux mes cheveux sont courts
mes cheveux sont courts j'avais lu un
truc un petit un petit extrait dans un
magazine où on avait carrément
psychologiser ma coupe de cheveux
c'est quand même un peu inquiétant
c'était oui un compenser cheveux elle
renonce à une certaine forme de féminité
et de fécondité j'étais là-bas ou alors
j'invente ma féminité aussi mais bon
c'est pas très nouveau non plus quand
même les années 90 avant et des femmes
aux cheveux courts donc j'ai pas trop
compris pourquoi c'était un vrai grand
débat j'avoue qu'à un moment j'ai même
regardé des interviews david bowie parce
que je veux c'est est ce que est ce
qu'on parle à david brut ses cheveux
parce qu'on parle de ça c'est orange
j'ai pas à trouver beaucoup d'exemples
donc en tirer des conclusions
féministe
on pourrait dire tu es féministe et
écoute de la variété française
il ya beaucoup de chansons de variétés
françaises qui sont très misogyne nous
sommes dans une société patriarcale donc
on pourrait dire tu es féministe et
trois petits points pour plein de choses
donc oui bien sûr je finissais j'écoute
les cetc de toute façon un petit peu
toujours moi ça m'a toujours gêné qu'on
stigmatise en particulier rap sur des
questions féminisme ou de culture alors
qu'en fait là il ya beaucoup de chansons
de dit oui aux variétés plus douce qui
ne sont absolument pas douze cantons les
rigodons j'ai fait un feat avec booba et
ça a été vécue comme un mini cataclysme
mais alors qu'en fait précisément
l'intérêt était de trouver ce qui
pouvait nous relier aussi en fait j'ai
trouvé ça étrange qu'on cherche à nous à
dire ce qui nous séparait alors qu'il y
avait des choses qui visiblement noronha
[Musique]
sûr que l'on m'a toujours beaucoup parlé
du coup j'ai toujours beaucoup répondu
sur cette question mais c'est pas mon
genre de l'éduquer journaliste est sûre
je m'absente devra expliquer le
vocabulaire ont lieu dans une
conversation
donc en fait j'ai besoin des toujours au
début de la conversation de devoir
définir ce que c'est que le coup hier
alors que aussi c'est une façon de pas
être défini bref au lieu pouvoir avancer
enfin il pouvoir tirer cette
conversation genre ah bon alors de là
comment est ce que vous avez un rapport
au son et à la production musicale donc
en fait on va toujours au début de la
conversation c'est ça qui est un peu
frustrant mais je pense que je vais
arrêter du coup de répondre de plus en
plus et je vais essayer de parler plus
en plus de musique parce que c'est vrai
que c'est un peu épuisant ci parce qu'en
fait je réponds puis après midi comment
est-ce que tu expliques qu'on pose la
question que tu répondes mais en fait
c'est sans fin et du coup je pense que
beaucoup de gens savent même pas que
j'ai fait même si j'exagère mais me
sentir courir s'est questionné cette
norme se déconstruire des constructions
qui nous sont imposées par par plein de
choses la publicité part parce qu'on
peut regarder au cinéma il ya là comme
le cuir c'est quand même une
contre-culture aussi quoi ça a été un
moment une réaction à une culture très
normée très édifiant quoi après le queer
c'est aussi esthétique ça me permets moi
de réfléchir à enfin mon premier album
j'ai mélangé kanye west et christophe et
je réfléchis à l'hybridité et ça fait
partie d'une réflexion sur l'impureté
sur un rapport au monde qui est pas dans
des absolus que qui que je t on aussi du
coin
[Musique]
choisir un nom de scène c'est pas à se
cacher au contraire ça peut être chose
de très beau quoi c'est juste une façon
de trouver sans moyen de s'accepter de
s'exprimer si j'ai commencé à choisir un
nom de scène en m'appelant christine je
voyais pas pourquoi je n'aurais pas le
droit de continuer à choisir alors un
livre de crise crouch je sais pas s'il
est traduit en français mais j'espère
qu'ils s'appellent island dick dit
qu'étant le nom d'un personnage mais
vous avez compris le jeune homme est en
fait dans ce bouquin une oeuvre
épistolaire un féministe il ya un moment
très intéressant où l auteur redis on
refuse toujours à la femme l'imagination
la projection la sublimation c'est à
dire qu'une femme elle est obligée
d'être dans un rapport de journal intime
c'est à dire qu'elle est incapable
d'avoir des constructions de se trouver
dans par ailleurs annonce n 2 est en
fait c'est vrai souvent souvent chez les
femmes on est on nous reproche souvent
d'être dans de la construction s'est vus
comme de la malhonnêteté alors que par
exemple chez bob dylan qui n'est pas son
vrai prénom c'est une démarche
artistique
enfin juste avant christine et ce
personnage là j'ai été très mal moi j'ai
fait une dépression fin est donc plein
de raisons parce que j'avais un chacun
bref mais aussi c'est à ce moment là où
en fait j'avais plus rien à perdre que
j'ai désappris une politesse que j'avais
une amie et je me suis dit mais en fait
je vais faire exactement ce que j'ai
envie faire j'en ai marre de m'excuser
quoi en fait je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire d'avoir une identité
enfin au sens où mon identité a - à la
était plurielle dès le début dès que
j'étais jeune quoi je ne sais pas
j'écrivais des nouvelles et jeu j'avais
déjà plaint alter ego et et
je pense qu'une identité n'est pas
solide elle est toujours en construction
en finlande re avoir 14 ans et 26 ans
pour mille choses se passent donc je
sais pas trop ce que ça veut dire
je suis toujours en train de questionner
ça aussi je suis en train de mon grand
plaisir aussi de se demander où je suis
et qui je suis